can women prey on men absolutely right
this is stored knowledge that we've
pretended we don't have everybody knows
it everybody and it's unbelievably
dangerous to talk about this I give
example in the book of the Indiana Jones
films one of the Indiana Jones films
there's a famous scene where the whole
class has sort of a very attractive
young women all looking moon Ellie and
Harrison Ford and his teaching and and
there are the sexy hot you know
archaeology guy which is of course
completely familiar in real life anyhow
he he's giving the class and one of the
women on the girls I mean they are girls
really in the class has written love you
on her eyelids and it and she blinks at
him so he can see this and yeah I find
this fascinating because this again yet
somehow sometimes it comes up as a meme
online still but everybody knew this
time it was so familiar as a type that
with a woman or even the young woman
making a really vert play for the male
it's so familiar there was in family
movies and what about a spinster with
the toy boy you know and we sort of
pretend that these types don't exist we
sort of denied ourselves access to
archetypes that we pretended don't exist
it's unlearning really important
learning yes
well because in in these things we're in
the realm of for a lot of this you know
because within the law as I saying
earlier there's just that we're in the
realm of manners and the manners manners
are things that you your best trying to
acquire as you go along from other
people and learning from your elders and
I think and the elders at the moment are
saying we don't know what we know we're
not passing it on don't touch don't know
let's figure it out for yourself yeah
and and by the way some of them are men
that's the know isn't it that's that be
home be home by one yeah but it's just
you know they say it's
complex it's complex but it's not as
complex as we're making it what do we do
to move forward them several things the
first thing is we have to realize what's
going on and like just get out of it we
have to get out of this we have to get
out of this zero-sum game particularly
the zero-sum game whereby in order for
we think for women to do better men have
to do worse or for gay people to thrive
straight people have to do worse or for
black people to thrive white people have
to as you've got to get out of this this
is just so unhealthy it's it's waste of
individual life and it's a terrible
opportunity cost for society because
none of it is fixable is my view you
know are things you can do worse there
are things you can do better but we're
never gonna fix it it there's never
going to be the lovely interlocking
Nirvana that means that we all move to
some perfect state it's just not the
case so what should we be doing and this
is the really this is this is the thing
and I think that a lot of clever people
and particularly people who have certain
advantages in their lives
I helped through this and they know how
to get through this era I give very
exact various examples of this the sort
of cuttlefish phenomenon among others
but my point is is that there are people
who've worked it out and I'd quite like
their knowledge that among other things
a lot of this is [ __ ] to be more
widely understood because we need to get
out of the other side of this in larger
numbers now my view is that this is this
is because it's partly just something
for people to do so it's a lifestyle
choice of its own and a hobby and a
religion among other things it's worth
thinking what what what should we be
doing then if we're not doing this but
let me put it this way I mean imagine if
we actually sold the identity politics
thing which they say it's not going to
happen and what would it look like it
would look like us saying it's great
I've worked out where I am in the
hierarchy this morning and I'm allowed
to speak between 11th
in 1132 and you do that for some decades
then you die now I'm not up for that and
I trust you aren't either
no no what could we be doing well I
think we should be hugely ambitious and
I don't have all the answers by any
means but I know that we should be much
more ambitious than that in what we're
gonna do I we have the 21st century
ahead of us we have better luck than
anyone in human history anyone not just
anyone alive today but anyone alive ever
so why would we be wasting our time
playing identity quick-fix politics I
would submit that we should try to get
ourselves off this in order to dream
bigger dreams to do really meaningful
things to not work out what we shouldn't
be doing and what we're not allowing
ourselves to do and what we don't think
is in our lane but to break out of that
you know the the the something a Jordan
Peterson and I and others have discussed
a few times in the past has been this
strange view of life in this era as if
as if the ideal life is to be harmless
like harmless from cradle to grave not
cause harm at least I didn't emit any
co2 and I never never upset anyone and I
never spoke when I shouldn't have spoken
and so on I just think we've got to
break out of that and say no no the aim
of this generation is not to just
shouldn't he's not just to be harmless
as our highest aspiration its to be
extraordinary to be great to be
inventive to be intelligent to be loving
to be caring to be great in all of our
personal relationships if we can and
recognize it will fail a great deal but
do as well as we can and then in the
rest of our lives be extraordinary and
and and and great and do things that
people will talk about
for generations afterwards and look out
with admiration you know we don't look
at the great buildings of the past that
have stayed standing and and look at
them with anything but or and I can't
see that in this generation if our
ambition is to look at our navel long
enough to believe we've understood
ourselves totally and then die I see
nobody standing looking at a statue of
that and think if anyone could do that
in marble and thinking those are the
guys
[Music]